calles vacías en el nuevo epicentro en
asia del coronavirus un rebrote del
virus llevó a las autoridades a declarar
un confinamiento parcial cerrando
restaurantes parques y centros
comerciales en las listas de java y bali
al principio del mes la nueva variante
delta contribuyó a un aumento de casos
desde inicios de julio que van alrededor
de 1000 al día la población busca
maneras de lidiar con el rebrote de
casos sea el masaje tangana vengo desde
el hospital llene de estanques en la
estación de oxígeno en la noche y vuelvo
a comprar 10 cilindros más
con una ocupación del casi 90 por ciento
en hospitales el gobierno refuerza el
suministro de oxígeno para aquellos que
no pueden acceder a una cama en yakarta
grupos de voluntarios han puesto en
marcha la entrega de comida a domicilio
para los que se encuentran aislados y la
gente no puede ir al hospital porque la
mayoría de salas de emergencias están
llenas y también hay una escasez de
oxígeno
decidimos crear esta cocina comunitaria
para ayudar a la gente de este barrio y
darles comida saludable que pueda
levantar su sistema inmune y se puedan
recuperar lo más pronto posible unda
porta cal en el momento que los casos de
coronavirus reportados a diario ahora
sobrepasan los números en india donde el
brote letal está bajando